[Música]
hace poco mi mejor amiga se puso a
llorar por un programa familiar cuando
me contó lo que había pasado y vi su
tristeza medida puede ayudar con ella
pero lo hice porque pensé que esas
lágrimas ajenas nos ayudarían demasiado
poco tiempo después esa tristeza que
dormí y la libere en una misa tocaron de
cajón peruano
cuando termine el evento mi mamá se
acercó a preguntarme por qué lloraba
cuando le conté lo que había pasado ella
me dijo y está sintiendo una emoción
maravillosa llamada empatía muchas
personas se sorprenden con una chica de
13 años habla sobre este tema porque
piensan que es un tema muy difícil toda
la verdad a mí siempre me gustaron los
temas difíciles
para los que no hacen que la empatía
empatía es ver con los ojos del otro
sentir con sumo corazón en sí ponerse
luego del otro
alguna vez se preguntaron cómo sería un
mundo lleno de personas empáticas
no habría guerras habría menos
competencia menos bullying habría más
comunicación y solidaridad más
compañerismo menos conflictos
la verdad
mostrarle empatía a alguien nos deja
abrir sus corazones y dejar de ser lo
más empáticos
todo esto empieza con un pequeño gesto
un pequeño gesto que nos dejaría hacer
una cadena empatía que transformaría a
toda nuestra sociedad
ya sé por qué cerraron que con un
pequeño gesto podemos transformar algo
tan arruinado
pero
y ahora le voy a dar cinco ejemplos de
pequeños gestos que algunos hacemos
todos los días y nos damos cuenta que
son tan importantes y los que no lo
hacemos estaría bueno empezar a hacerlos
primero saludar saludar saludar a
alguien nos deja hacer
se lo da a alguien de la hacemos más
cuando sudamos a alguien lo hacemos más
feliz y esa persona va a sentir que es
parte de nuestra vida dice a sentir
importante segundo contacto visual para
mí es lo más importante porque cuando
bebes a los ojos de la otra persona pues
ver lo que en serio está sintiendo si
esa sonrisa oculta algo o si esa persona
está nerviosa como yo
tercero preguntar cómo estás esto solo a
tomar unos cinco minutos
de preocuparnos por el prójimo cuarto
estar atento y estar atento es observar
y conocer al otro que el otro pueda
sentirse descuidado por alguien
quinto darle una mano por favor no
digitalmente
finalmente aunque parezca poco ayudar es
muy importante no importa el problema
que sea con la mudanza o con lo
económico esa persona se hace inspirada
por ese acto y baha quiere ayudar a
otros y a vos también entonces eso
también formaría una especie de cadena
de empatía como dije anteriormente
ahora
le voy a contar algo que la verdad me
pasó a mí cuando me nombran empatía me
suena a algo que me basé ese interesarme
más y un día la verdad que empecé a
investigar y el contra algo llamado
inteligencia emocional
sal de ese pensar y la inteligencia era
saber un cálculo matemático o sobre
historia pero no hay algo más importante
llamado inteligencia emocional que nos
humaniza
como el colegio nos enseña
matemáticas historia geografía nos
tendría que enseñar sobre la empatía yo
pienso que sí porque esos conocimientos
están en los libros pero empatía no la
empatía se aprende de tu entorno y que
mejor que aprender con tus maestros y
con tus amigos
ahora como cierre les propongo una tarea
o un ejercicio para el que lo quiera
hacer ahora mirar a la persona que le
tiene al lado mirarlo a los ojos
preguntarse cuesta que está ocultando
algo si es así visita ayuda
ahora los invito
al practicar este ejercicio en su vida
cotidiana
porque en fin es tan fácil como respirar
y sonreír gracias
[Aplausos]